hey there is there a project you're
working on
i know more than you all right
santiago shall we join forces oh smart
teaming up with the reigning champ again
with this nonsense i'm the reigning
champ the only thing you won last heist
was a lifetime of mediocre heterosexual
intercourse with jake
how dare you no one thinks you won last
year wow really thought that how dare
you was gonna be linked to his mean sex
comment but okay
come on michael you're you're
interrupting you're kidding me god
you say radon is silent but deadly and
then you expect me not to make farting
noises with my mouth
what is this please sit down you know
what we're not gonna die of radon we're
gonna die of boredom
yeah right and if i had a gun
with two bullets and i was in a room
with hitler bin laden and toby
i would shoot toby twice no that's not
okay you're all right really funny and
then you went too far i
would kill bin laden and then toby no
but still
check your email the greatest thing that
could ever happen has just happened
the girl who beat you for high school
valedictorian died no
yeah of all the weirdos i've met around
here you're the worst
with your creepy don knott's face that
ridiculous hitler youth haircut
excellent what about my chin what about
your chin kenneth i've seen bigger chins
on a premature baby
we should really have the office's air
quality tested and we have radon coming
from below we have asbestos in the
ceilings
these are silent killers you are the
silent killer go back to the annex
you'll see sergeant why am i here i'm
always incredibly appropriate
in high school i was voted most
appropriate ooh self burn
those are rare i find that appalling
oh yeah well i find stretch pants
appalling but i'm too much of a lady to
mention it fat ass
i'm sorry for what's about to happen
right now just know that i don't mean it
don't mean what what group home did you
escape from that you would dare talk to
me like some plumber's wife
in front of ron gordon and bob overmeyer
i don't even know who those guys are oh
really your ignorance was obvious when
you waddled up to me with your
thin-lipped mouth full of greasy peasant
food
and addressed me by my christian name in
front of the gentleman from fairfield
that's fairfield connecticut lemon ge
headquarters but how would you know that
with your nine
40 years of public education and daytime
television viewing if you
ever pull a bush league stunt like that
again i'm gonna have you writing promos
for arena football so fast that'll make
your inexplicably small head
spin
[Music]
i thought you might like a fresh set of
pillows are you trying to smother me
help the [ __ ] nurse is trying to
smother me to death with a pillow
okay never mind stay back [ __ ]
jim you're six eleven and you weigh 90
pounds
gumby has a better body than you boom
roasted
dwight you're a kiss ass boom roasted
pam you failed art school
boom roasted meredith you've slept with
so many guys you're starting to look
like one
boom roasted kevin i can't decide
between a fat joke and a dumb joke boom
roasted
creed your teeth called your breath
stinks boom roasted
angela where's angela well there you are
i didn't see you behind that grain of
rice
boom roasted stanley you crush your wife
during sex and your heart sucks boom
roasted
oscar you are
oscar you're gay
wow andy cornell call they think you
suck
and you're gayer than oscar oh roasted
karen tell grace you should fire you
grace tell will to redirect his anger at
his mother where it belongs
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys what's up oh oh my god
what are you wearing you're making me
gay i don't know if i made it clear but
i don't want any sex offenders in our
parks catalog
i will photoshop his face can you
photoshop your life with better
decisions
jerry okay april depression isn't that
just a fancy word for feeling
bummed out dwight you ignorant [ __ ] he's
just got a real turd of a personality
yeah but you two seem like a couple of
wet blankets as well
did you rent pretty woman again
come on give it up honey the only thing
you two have in common is horse teeth
and bad taste in men
you gotta sit i'm sure you'd like to
take some weight off your clothing
hooves
calling me the devil how original
raymond actually i was calling you a
goat
you goat
okay that is no they don't understand
who they have supposed to do idiot i am
trying to get your back
are you calling me an idiot did you ever
talk to me that way
you pathetic short little man you don't
have any friends or any family
or any land
as soon as i'm done here i'm gonna head
to the airport get the hell out of this
trash country where everyone is either a
criminal or a spider
i suppose you think that they're more
nurturing
than i am mother there are terrorist
cells that are more nurturing than you
are
what would you say holt thinks my
biggest flaw is who cares what holt
thinks
what's most important is what i think
your biggest fly is
and there are so many to choose from too
competitive prone to jealousy
a bit of a kill joy your shame
cigarettes oh my god
but your biggest flaw is you suck at
throwing away your secret lists
[Music]
we at the end of the night are going to
give the check
to an actual group of boy scouts right
toby we're gonna
actually i didn't think it was
appropriate to invite children since
it's uh
you know there's gambling and alcohol
and it's in our dangerous warehouse
and it's a school night and you know
hooters is catering
you know is that enough is that enough
should i keep going
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun
or exciting you make it not
that way i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
okay spare me this sanctimonious lecture
you never cared about me
in the words of one of my actual friends
you're basic
it's a human insult it's devastating
you're devastated right now
santiago i may need you to come in for a
bit on saturday
again are you kidding me man
i'm sorry let's start fresh hi
oh my god what just happened her mind
finally
snapped like a stale breadstick
i wrote that i'm liz lemon
[Music]
if your man is over 30 and still wears a
name tag
to work that's a deal breaker but not
you mike
that's not you mike leave my cutout
hello
oh okay oh
okay you know i'm gonna do the same
thing to your cutout oh wait you don't
have one because you're
nobody
another successful interaction with a
man
you